what we have here our specials are we
have a uh steak that is 3D printed um
and it comes with the idea of mashed
potatoes and you can also get uh some
virtual broccoli and you will leave so
hungry your steak could soon be 3D
printed
yum that's if you live in Europe Israeli
company redefined meat has struck a
partnership with importer geraldi meat
this is so European distribution of its
new meat steak cuts so it's not startup
is hoping to establish its products as
an alternative to conventionally
produced meat I'm so
hungry oh just seeing those machines go
back and forth
make making that steak appear out of
nowhere God that just gets me salivating
dude operates large scale meat printers
at its oh dude nothing makes me hungrier
than hearing the words meat
printer
oh [__] dude hey you got a meat printer
at your house oh let's do the barbecue
there hold on N dude yeah my Grill's
fine but my friend Bruce has got a meat
printer holy [__] you take one One Taste
of these [__] virtual
Meats Headquarters South of T what do
you want a ribeye or what do you have ah
whatever you want I just [__] put it
in the computer I plug it in what do you
want you want
duck as well as in a new Factory in the
Netherlands you know what's funny is why
do they make it look like how it looks
just make it look like
anything make it look so different you
can it'll still taste the same company's
3D printers project yonel explains how
it works imagine how bad the first ones
are that they made when I want to make
my steak I can I have a a libr
of a few different slabs I can choose
each one of them and I can adjust it
accordingly I can Define the amount of
marbling yeah this guy the internal fat
or the external fat and then now I can I
can start and go and print it and
produce it so I'm putting it this is my
que this is my my timeline for today I
know that in an hour something from now
I will need to refill the the machine
with new new material but now directly
into the printing process and you can
see how how the process start to build
layer by layer and then you eat it and
everybody gets cancer immediately um so
we print the meat the company makes its
products from ingredients including soy
and pea protein looks kind of good fruit
nutritional yeasts and coconut fat
co-founder and chief
executive shitr said redefine meat was
launching TLO and strip loin steaks in
the past two years we have been working
deeply on understanding meat and what
makes meat so exciting and we identified
a few components that we can recreate
from plants and have the same exact
performance as the tissue of animal
meat combination of additive such a [__]
the exact feeling you're I'm eating a
meat just being like ah what a gorgeous
performance experience God this is a
gorgeous performance in my mouth coming
from an animal without the use of the
animal plant-based meat alternative you
still got to cook it look ly popular in
recent years you ever have a a [__]
um what do you call it impossible Burger
it it it's good but it doesn't taste
like meat and then
also it's really bad for
you hey just eat the
cow hey print your
meat isn't that a doesn't that isn't
meat printing another uh word for
masturbation manag startup Nova meat M
I'll be right down I'm printing my meat
is also using 3D printing technology to
manufacture vegetarian Stakes but the
early hype about plant-based meat
Alternatives has ebbed as inflation and
recession worries have driven some
customers back cheap animal meat product
$400,000 companies such as us-based
beyond meat have cut their sales
outlooks redefined meat however has big
Ambitions it's new meat is currently
available in Israel Britain the
Netherlands and Germany everyone in
those countries will be dead within 10
years this is
crazy um it also will be for sure
cheaper and so every store is going to
have it like McDonald's is going to just
be
[__] fake ass meat
paa printed meat paa
3D printed steak